عشرات الاسرائيليين يتظاهرون امام مقر
اجتماع بلينكن مع هسو مطالبين بالافراج عن
الاسر
ن حتى لو هم يطالبون
بالافراج عقد صفقه اسرى شامله حتى لو كان
الثمن وقف تام لاطلاق النار وهؤلاء يتهمون
حتى حكومه نتنياهو بانها اهملت قضيه
ابنائهم واقربائهم المحتجزين في قطاع غزه
لذلك هم يحاولون ان يؤثر
على مسار هذه الاجتماعات ودفع وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه للضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من اجل التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق
النار وان لا تكون المرحله الثالثه من هذه
الحرب هي مجرد مرحله اخرى مع استمرار هذه
الحرب وفق ما يصرح به القاده الاسرائيليون
واخرهم نتنياهو وجلن امس الذان قالا بان
الحرب
ستتواصل وستستغرق اشهر اضافيه اخرى وانها
لن تتوق ولذلك هؤلاء قلقين جدا ثانيا هناك
تقارير باتت مقلقه بالنسبه لهم عن ان
الاوضاع الصحيه لابنائهم واقربائهم
المحتجزين اخذه بالتدهور حسب تعبيرهم كما
ان الحرب البريه الاسرائيليه والقصف الجوي
الاسرائيلي عرض الكثيرين منهم عرض حياه
الكثيرين منهم للخطر هم يتظاهرون الان
للتاثير وهذا الموضوع الاساسي الذي يبحثه
الرئيس هيرتسوغ مع وزير الخارجيه بلينكن
الى جانب قضيه محكمه هاي التي ستلتئم يوم
الخميس والجمعه للنظر بالالتماس الذي
قدمته جنوب افريقيا شكرا لك وليد العمري
مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من رام الله